Buonasera, siamo arrivati alla terza tappa di questa cavalcata attraverso il risorgimento
visto attraverso i grandi personaggi che lo hanno fatto. Garibaldi potrebbe sembrare il
più facile da raccontare visto che era un personaggio così colorito e io mi sono trovato
alla fine invece a avere più difficoltà con lui che non con gli altri, a cercare di tracciare
un ritratto equilibrato e a cercare di stare anche proprio in equilibrio fra i giudizi che
si davano su di lui allora, molto contrastanti, quelli che si danno oggi ancora più contrastanti
in modo addirittura eccessivo. Alla fine io ho pensato di cominciare in questo modo, ho
pensato di cominciare ricordando un aspetto che noi oggi rischiamo di dimenticarci e che
invece va tenuto in considerazione quanto merita, cioè il fatto che Garibaldi ai suoi
tempi era un uomo incredibilmente popolare e incredibilmente amato, non soltanto in Italia
ma in tutta Europa e anche in America a dir la verità. Il tipo di notorietà, fama e amore
popolare per Garibaldi è qualche cosa che nel mondo di oggi secondo me non esiste neanche
per le star dello spettacolo. E allora io vorrei cominciare raccontandovi cosa succede
quando Garibaldi decide di fare un viaggio in Inghilterra. Siamo nel 1864, quindi quattro
anni dopo l'impresa dei Mille. Garibaldi decide di andare in Inghilterra per vari motivi, quando
si viene a sapere di questo suo desiderio il direttore di una compagnia di navigazione inglese
gli manda apposta un piroscafo a prenderlo. Arriva, sbarca Southampton, dove trova una
folla enorme col sindaco in testa che lo acclama e grida urrà. L'ammiraglio comandante
della base navale di Portsmouth, che è abbastanza vicina, lo invita a visitare la base navale,
organizza una manovra in mare con finto combattimento a fuoco della flotta inglese in onore di Garibaldi.
Dopodiché deve andare a Londra, gli preparano un treno speciale che sfreccia verso Londra
sventolando la bandiera italiana. Quando arriva a Londra trova 500.000 persone che lo aspettano,
secondo la questura, non secondo gli organizzatori. Esce dal treno alla stazione, c'è la carrozza
del Duca di Sutherland che lo aspetta, perché sarà ospite a casa del Duca di Sutherland. La
carrozza ci mette sei ore per andare dalla stazione al Palazzo del Duca, talmente tanta
è la folla che preme tutto intorno per vedere, per toccare Garibaldi. Quando la carrozza entra
nel cortile del Palazzo, fanno appena in tempo a scendere e poi la carrozza crolla a pezzi,
perché la pressione della folla l'aveva distrutta e tenuta insieme contemporaneamente
fino all'ultimo. Garibaldi va a pranzo dal primo ministro, va a cena dal ministro degli
esteri, è acclamato dalla popolazione inglese in senso trasversale, nel senso che ci sono
le duchesse che gli mandano lettere d'amore e gli operai che lo invitano nelle loro società.
E lui accetta questi inviti in modo trasversale. Lo invitano a Eton, la più famosa e la più
snob delle public school inglesi, e lui va a Eton dove gli fanno trovare tutti gli allievi
schierati che lo acclamano gridando urrà in suo onore. Ma va anche a visitare i primi sindacati
che da non molto tempo sono nati, va ai banchetti operai. Questo magari è un dettaglio
che si potrebbe anche evitare, ma insomma risulta che a casa della duca di Sutherland
le domestiche della casa vendevano bottiglie dell'acqua in cui Garibaldi si era lavato
la mattina. Quindi immaginate appunto c'è la catinella, lui si lava la faccia, dopodiché
le domestiche imbottigliano e fuori c'è la coda della gente che vuole comprare quest'acqua.
Il principe ereditario, sarà il futuro re Edoardo VII, torna apposta a Londra per conoscerlo.
Ora, io direi che questo sarebbe già un racconto che vale la pena, che ci potrebbe far meditare
un pochino. Quale altro italiano ci viene in mente che potrebbe andare in Inghilterra
ed essere accolto da 500.000 persone festanti a Londra? E magari ci potrebbe anche far piacere
il fatto che un grande italiano vada in Inghilterra e gli facciano trovare un treno con la bandiera
italiana che sventola fuori. Almeno ad alcuni di noi potrebbe far piacere.
C'è qualcuno che non è tanto contento. Ci sono delle minoranze che non sono tanto contente
di avere Garibaldi a Londra e di vedere queste accoglienze trionfali. Ed è molto istruttivo
vedere chi non è contento. Da un lato non è contenta la regina Vittoria. La regina Vittoria
dichiara che si sente, notate che suo figlio invece è arrivato di corsa per conoscere Garibaldi,
ma la regina non è contenta e dice anzi io mi vergogno di governare una nazione capace di
simili follie. Dopodiché riflette, si dimentica per un attimo che appunto alcune duchesse di
corte stanno mandando lettere d'amore a Garibaldi e Vittoria conclude che però in definitiva è
soltanto la teppaglia, la plebaglia più infima che acclama Garibaldi. Dopodiché la stessa
Vittoria scrive, sì, è una cosa vergognosa perché insomma gli inglesi sono veramente del
tutto impazziti per Garibaldi. Vittoria lo scrive con due R. E, dopo tutto, cito sempre
dalla regina Vittoria il suo diario. Onesto, disinteressato e coraggioso, Garibaldi lo è
certamente, ma è un capo rivoluzionario. Gli altri che non sono contenti, almeno ne cito
uno in particolare, Marx non è per niente contento. Marx che è a Londra trova che questa
enorme popolarità di Garibaldi è una manifestazione di imbecillità della folla, perché quello stesso
Garibaldi che per Vittoria e per tanti altri, compreso Cavour, compreso Vittoria Emanuele,
è un pericoloso rivoluzionario, ecco, visto dal punto di vista di un teorico del comunismo
come Marx, invece è un ingenuo, è uno che si fa manovrare, è uno che appunto va dagli
operai ma va anche delle duchesse, non è una persona seria insomma. E dunque, agli occhi
di Marx il fatto che le folle siano così pronte ad acclamarlo dimostra quanto quelle stesse
folle siano immature. Ebbene, Garibaldi, se noi volessimo collocarlo in uno spettro
politico, dovremmo riflettere precisamente su chi non era contento di vederlo acclamato
dalle masse. C'era un'opposizione a Garibaldi da destra, tutto il mondo più conservatore,
più reazionario, legittimista, monarchico, aveva una paura maledetta di quest'uomo che
vedeva appunto come un sovversivo, un rivoluzionario, un terrorista, un pirata e così via. Dall'altra
parte, in realtà, chi si sentiva veramente di sinistra non si identificava affatto con
Garibaldi. Non soltanto Marx, ma anche Mazzini, dopo un iniziale momento di contatto, in realtà
sarà sempre molto lontano da Garibaldi. E questo in realtà per un motivo ben preciso,
che Garibaldi, anche se aveva idee, e lo vedremo, molto avanzate e che agli occhi di molti
potevano sembrare sovversive, nella congiuntura politica del risorgimento ha sempre consapevolmente
tenuto una posizione moderata, che è quello che gli ha permesso poi, in realtà, alla fine
di realizzare i suoi disegni. Quindi Garibaldi è tutt'altro che un estremista e io credo che
questa sia una chiave importante per interpretarlo.
l'altra cosa su cui, ripeto, vale la pena di riflettere è il fatto che quest'uomo era,
se non dalle regine e dai comunisti, da tutto il resto dei comuni mortali, adorato, estimato,
estimato anche dai suoi nemici. Avremo spesso occasione di citare testimonianze di avversari
politici che dicono, sì, è un ingenuo, è uno che si lascia manipolare, ma non c'è uno
che non dica, però certo, è onesto, ammirevole, magnifico e così via. Questo vale la pena
di ricordarlo in un'epoca come la nostra, in cui se uno digita su Google il nome di
Garibaldi, il primo sito che viene fuori è la biografia su Wikipedia e il secondo sito
che viene fuori è un sito, che non voglio neanche nominare, così pieno di bugie su Garibaldi,
carico di un tale astio, di una tale ostilità preconcetta nei confronti di Garibaldi, che
fa sbalordire, fa sbalordire pensando invece a chi era Garibaldi per gli uomini del suo
tempo. Vorrei sottolineare ancora, perché è una cosa che non ci ricordiamo più, che
Garibaldi era celeberrimo e popolarissimo già ben prima dell'impresa dei Mille. Noi italiani
lo associamo soprattutto a quello naturalmente. Garibaldi, l'impresa dei Mille del 1860, già
dieci anni prima era uscita una biografia di Garibaldi. Già nel 1850 viene stampata a Torino
una biografia di Garibaldi. Non solo, nel 1859 escono a New York e a Londra le memorie di
Garibaldi, tradotte in inglese. Quindi un uomo celeberrimo, celebre in diversi continenti,
già prima dell'impresa dei Mille. Dopo l'impresa dei Mille, in tarda età, è certamente uno
degli uomini più famosi del mondo. C'è un aneddoto che sembra però vero, è un po'
complicato raccontarla tutta ma scorciamo. C'è una figlia di Garibaldi, illegittima, che
a un certo punto, per motivi che non stiamo a dire, si trova in difficoltà a Creta. Si
trova in difficoltà a Creta, è quasi prigioniera in casa, scrive al padre, scrive una lettera
al padre chiedendogli aiuto, la butta dalla finestra, scrivendo sulla busta semplicemente
al generale Garibaldi. Una lettera buttata dalla finestra di una casa in un villaggio
cretese, come tutto indirizzo, al generale Garibaldi, arriva a Caprera una settimana
dopo.
La fama di Garibaldi certamente riposa su due aspetti. Da un lato l'enorme ammirazione per
il suo idealismo, ma dall'altro ha anche una grande ammirazione per gli aspetti pittoreschi
e avventurosi del personaggio. E su questi aspetti pittoreschi e avventurosi io vorrei
fermarmi un momento all'inizio, poi passeremo a cose politicamente più concrete. Ma non
si può dimenticare che Garibaldi ha una biografia strabiliante, è un uomo che in vita
sua ha fatto di tutto e io ho provato a fare qualche statistica, perché veramente ci sono
cose che soltanto a livello statistico si possono, quante volte è stato arrestato in vita
sua, eccetera. Cominciamo col dire che Garibaldi in vita sua ha fatto i mestieri più diversi.
Lui di suo era un marinaio. Garibaldi nasce, come sappiamo tutti, a Nizza, che allora, quando
nasce lui è suddito di Napoleone, tanto per cambiare, e infatti viene registrato all'anagrafe
come Joseph Marie Garibaldi. Nizza è una città a metà fra la Liguria e la Provenza,
ma Garibaldi è ligure. Il babbo è di Genova, la mamma è di Loano, sono una famiglia di marinai
Liguri. E Garibaldi da ragazzo fa il marinaio. Fare il marinaio vuol dire che si imbarca a
16 anni e su una nave a vela fa il viaggio fino al Mar Nero, fino a Odessa. E per nove
anni Garibaldi fa prima il marinaio e poi il capitano di bastimenti mercantili a vela,
perché prende il brevetto di capitano di lungo corso. Quindi lui è un marinaio professionista
che porta navi a vela, ripeto, in Turchia, in Russia. E ancora più tardi, a metà della
sua vita, all'inizio degli anni 50, quando è già diventato famoso come rivoluzionario,
ha partecipato alla prima guerra di indipendenza, poi all'infelice avventura della Repubblica
Romana, c'è già stata la fuga, la morte di sua moglie Anita, è già un personaggio
celeberrimo, però è costretto alla fuga dall'Italia e cosa fa? Si rimette a fare il
capitano di lungo corso e a metà della sua vita di nuovo comanda navi mercantili, sempre
a vela, che fanno viaggi come per esempio dal Peru alla Cina, dagli Stati Uniti all'Inghilterra
e così via. Quindi un uomo di mare a pieno titolo. Il che non gli impedisce a un certo
punto, quando è ancora giovane, siccome si trova a Costantinopoli e per vari motivi
decide di fermarsi lì e vive a Costantinopoli, a Istanbul, per due anni e mezzo, Garibaldi, e si
mantiene facendo il precettore privato di italiano, francese e matematica ai figli di
una signora italiana che abita a Istanbul. Diversamente dai signori di cui abbiamo parlato
nei giorni scorsi, Cavour e Vittorio Emanuele, Garibaldi è uno che con le lingue ci sa fare.
È stato allevato anche lui tra il Provenzale e il Ligure, ma nell'impero francese, però è
italiano, padroneggia bene il francese e l'italiano, sa anche l'inglese, avendo vissuto in Sudamerica
sa lo spagnolo, sa il portoghese, quindi insomma siamo proprio su un altro piano. Tanto che può
fare l'insegnante di italiano e di francese a Istanbul. Fa il commerciante all'ingrosso
di pastasciutta in Brasile. Per due anni in Brasile Garibaldi ha dei bastimenti suoi in
società con degli amici e trasporta spaghetti da un porto all'altro del Brasile. Fa l'insegnante
di matematica in Uruguay, anche lì prima di scoprire la sua vera vocazione e arruolarsi
nell'esercito dell'Uruguay insegna per un po' matematica. Sempre nei primi anni 50, quando
è già famoso ma ha dovuto fuggire dall'Italia, si ferma per un annetto scarso a New York e a
New York fa l'operaio in una fabbrica di candele. Fabrica di candele che peraltro apparteneva
a Meucci, il famoso inventore del telefono, buon amico di Garibaldi. Ecco, per dire che il
personaggio è solo l'inizio, degli aspetti pittoreschi della vita di Garibaldi. Mi vorrei
fermare un istante su questa cosa del Garibaldi che vive a Costantinopoli, che vive a New York,
per accennare a una conseguenza, una cosa che ho imparato su questo, che nemmeno io sapevo
così chiaramente. Quando Garibaldi arriva a Costantinopoli, 1831 credo, ci trova la società
degli operai italiani a Costantinopoli. C'è un gruppo di immigrati italiani che si
assistono a vicenda e sono proprio questi italiani che lo accolgono, gli trovano la
signora che ha i figli e ha bisogno di un precettore e così via. Quando va a New York
ci trova ovviamente associazioni e lì addirittura giornali di immigrati italiani. Così come
quando comincerà, ne parleremo subito, a fare il militare al servizio di vari stati
sudamericani, una delle cose che farà sarà arruolare una legione italiana arruolata
fra gli emigrati italiani. Quello su cui vorrei battere è questo, italiani. Perché noi oggi
in fondo, nella confusione che regna intorno a tutta la questione del risorgimento, dell'unità
d'Italia, dell'identità italiana, finiamo quasi per avere l'impressione che in realtà
l'Italia non esistesse, che fosse stata inventata, che sia una cosa che è stata imposta dall'alto.
Ecco, è molto istruttivo sapere che se un italiano arrivava a Costantinopoli nel 1831
ci trovava il circolo degli operai italiani, i quali non si definivano né piemontesi né
lombardi né toscani né niente, ma italiani. E questo dappertutto regolarmente.
Altri aspetti avventurosi della vita di Garibaldi. Ho contato quante volte è stato arrestato
in vita sua. Nove volte in tutto è stato arrestato. La cosa pittoresca è che le prime due volte è
stato arrestato dalla polizia russa in Crimea, dove era arrivato appunto come secondo su un
bastimento e devo dire non sono arresti eroici. La prima volta è arrestato per schiamazzi
notturni, ma aveva 25 anni. Poi lo condannano agli arresti domiciliari a bordo, lui scende
lo stesso dalla barca e lo arrestano di nuovo. Quindi è riuscito a farsi arrestare dalla polizia
russa, dalla polizia francese, perché durante le sue fughe è entrato in Francia illegalmente.
È stato arrestato dall'esercito argentino, che lo ha anche torturato. È stato arrestato dalla
polizia uruguayana per aver insultato l'ambasciatore del Brasile. È stato arrestato dalla polizia dei
Savoia quando c'era ancora il regno di Sardegna e poi tre volte dalla polizia italiana ad Aspromonte
e in altre due vicende conlegate con la faccenda di Roma, di Mentana, eccetera.
Nove arresti, una condanna a morte, quando era ancora molto giovane, quando si è fatto
coinvolgere dai mazziniani, è il motivo per cui poi se ne va in Sud America, insomma,
perché è condannato a morte dalla magistratura piemontese. È stato ferito in battaglia sei
volte. La prima volta, già dimenticavo gli arrembaggi dei pirati greci, scusatemi, perché
quando conduceva navi dell'Egeo, quelli erano mari poco sicuri e ci sono stati quattro
arrembaggi di pirati greci a navi su cui era imbarcato Garibaldi. Una volta c'è stato
anche lo scontro e Garibaldi è stato ferito la prima volta. Poi è stato ferito in battaglia
altre sei volte in tutto. È stato ufficiale di sei eserciti diversi, perché in Sud America,
e adesso lo racconteremo bene, ma diciamo intanto rapidamente che si è arruolato in una
Repubblica che adesso non esiste più, la Repubblica di Rio Grande, dove è stato nominato
comandante della Marina. Poi si è arruolato in Uruguay e anche lì è diventato comandante
della Marina Uruguayana. È stato generale del governo provvisorio Lombardo nel 48, al
tempo delle cinque giornate. È stato generale della Repubblica Romana nel 49. È stato generale
del Regno di Sardegna, quindi dei Savoia, e poi del Regno d'Italia. E finalmente ha fatto
ancora in tempo da vecchio a diventare generale della Repubblica Francese. Durante la
guerra franco-prussiana. Naturalmente è stato cittadino di tutti questi paesi e anche
di altri ancora. Lui era nato cittadino francese, poi cittadino del Regno di Sardegna, ma quando
era emigrato in America, e non sapeva che sarebbe tornato, ha chiesto la cittadinanza
americana. Su questo c'è qualche mancanza di chiarezza, nel senso che gli è andato
subito il passaporto, ma pare che allora il passaporto americano lo dessero con una certa
facilità. Chi è andato con pignoleria a verificare dice che la pratica della cittadinanza
non è andata in porto e quindi tecnicamente lui non era cittadino americano, ma credeva
di esserlo. Tant'è vero che quando durante la guerra civile americana Lincoln gli offre
un comando, lui discutendone con gli amici dice beh sì, io di questo paese sono cittadino,
quindi ci potrei anche andare. E ha preso anche la cittadinanza peruviana a un certo punto,
perché per prendere il comando di un mercantile peruviano la legge locale prevedeva la cittadinanza
e quindi è stato anche cittadino del Perù. È stato, ho quasi finito con le statistiche,
ma ancora questa permettetemela, è stato membro del Parlamento in cinque paesi diversi, perché
è stato membro del Parlamento in Uruguay, è stato membro del Parlamento nel Regno di
Sardegna, eletto nel 48 e poi nel 60, è stato membro del Parlamento all'Assemblea
Costituente della Repubblica Romana, il primo Parlamento in Italia eletto a suffragio universale,
poi è stato deputato del Regno d'Italia dal 61 in poi ed è riuscito anche a essere deputato
della Repubblica Francese nel 1871, quando appunto era accorso in difesa dei francesi
contro i prussiani. Bene, al di là degli aspetti pittoreschi, quello che va sottolineato
di Garibaldi è che noi sbaglieremmo di grosso se lo pensassimo soltanto nella prospettiva
del patriota italiano. Garibaldi è senza alcun dubbio un patriota italiano, è molto
convinto, ma prima ancora si sente cittadino del mondo e si sente coinvolto nelle vicende
che riguardano la libertà e le lotte per la libertà in tutto il mondo. C'è un episodio
specifico che è l'inizio di questa sua crociata personale per la libertà. Nel 1833 Garibaldi,
che quindi aveva 26 anni, è imbarcato per l'appunto su una di quelle tali navi che vanno
a Costantinopoli e su questa nave c'è imbarcato un gruppo di strani personaggi, sono i San Simoniani.
I San Simoniani erano un gruppo francese di socialisti in origine, che poi però a partire
dall'idea socialista avevano sviluppato una loro concezione molto particolare. Era un movimento
pacifista, libertario, che predicava l'eguaglianza, che predicava la parità della donna e che aveva
addirittura fondato una nuova religione basata sul principio del libero amore. Garibaldi sta
dei mesi sulla stessa nave con questa gente, parla con loro, rimane incantato. E da loro viene
convinto appunto che un vero uomo non può restare chiuso dentro i vincoli del suo patriottismo
nazionale, ma deve sentirsi cittadino del mondo. E lui stesso nelle sue memorie, raccontando questo
incontro decisivo con i San Simoniani, dice da loro ho imparato appunto che un uomo che combatte
per la sua patria, sì se combatte per difenderla è un soldato da rispettare, se combatte in una
guerra di aggressione è sempre un soldato e non è neanche da rispettare, ma che l'uomo il quale
facendosi cosmopolita adotta l'umanità per patria e va ad offrire la spada ed il sangue ad ogni popolo
che lotta contro la tirannia è più di un soldato, è un eroe. Garibaldi non era uno che avesse pure
della retorica, assolutamente. Ebbene, Garibaldi, folgorato a 26 anni, decide che lui vuole essere
proprio quello. Lui vuole essere il cosmopolita che si batte contro i tiranni, che si batte per la
libertà in tutto il mondo. Nella sua ingenuità vuole essere quell'eroe. Nella sua ingenuità,
salvo che sia riuscito. E effettivamente si è costruito in tutta la sua vita una carriera di
eroe al servizio della libertà. Cosa vuol dire al servizio della libertà? Qui bisogna fermarci un
pochino a raccontare la vicenda sudamericana di Garibaldi. Voi ricordate che Garibaldi è definito
l'eroe dei due mondi? Questo perché ben prima di venire a combattere in Italia ha combattuto e a lungo
in Sudamerica. E su queste imprese sudamericane di Garibaldi c'è spesso confusione, ci sono spesso
anche appunto bugie, invenzioni, menzogne. Quali sono i fatti? I fatti sono che in Sudamerica è un
continente in ebollizione in quel momento. Voi dovete pensare che in Sudamerica, pochissimo popolato,
è già pieno di immigrati, fra l'altro molti italiani, ce ne sono dappertutto, è appena uscito dal regime
coloniale spagnolo e portoghese. I confini dei nuovi paesi non sono chiari. Sono nati tutti i
paesi sudamericani che conosciamo anche noi oggi, il Brasile, l'Argentina, l'Uruguay, ma questi paesi
sono nati nel disordine, nella rivoluzione, nella guerra civile e sono paesi dove chi comanda è un'oligarchia
di grandi proprietari terrieri e di generali che hanno i loro eserciti privati, di gauchos e che si combattono
e che tutti naturalmente proclamano di combattere per l'indipendenza, per la libertà del loro paese,
l'uno contro l'altro, l'Uruguay contro l'Argentina. Ecco, a Garibaldi è stato spesso rivolto all'accusa
di essere un ingenuo e di credere a tutto quello che gli dicevano. Può anche darsi. Certamente lui ha
creduto in pieno che queste guerre fossero guerre per la libertà e si è arruolato dove gli sembrava che ci
fosse da combattere per la libertà. Il primo paese dove si arruola è un paese che oggi non esiste più
perché la sua guerra di indipendenza l'ha persa. Si chiamava la Repubblica del Rio Grande ed è uno
degli stati del Brasile. È un paese grande come la Gran Bretagna, per intenderci, non è uno staterello
da ridere. È un paese grande come la Gran Bretagna che per parecchi anni ha combattuto contro il Brasile,
che allora era un impero, con tanto di imperatore del Brasile sul trono, per affermare la sua
indipendenza. Garibaldi che vive lì per un po' di tempo, vive a Rio de Janeiro, commercia in spaghetti
per l'appunto, come sappiamo, quando viene a sapere che c'è questa insurrezione del Rio Grande,
questa guerra di indipendenza, immediatamente parte e va ad arruolarsi. Ed essendo un marinaio esperto
gli danno il comando della Marina del Rio Grande, che poi sono due barche all'inizio, credo.
Comunque, combatte lì per diversi anni, guadagnandosi fama, popolarità e anche un sacco
di nemici, naturalmente. Poi quando la Repubblica del Rio Grande finisce male, lui si trasferisce
in Uruguay, a Montevideo appunto per un po' insegna matematica, e poi però scoppia la guerra
anche lì, perché l'Argentina vuole annettersi l'Uruguay e l'Uruguay invece vuole essere indipendente.
E Garibaldi immediatamente si arruola nella lotta per la libertà dell'Uruguay. Anche lì lo
fanno comandante della flotta, che però è una flotta un po' più seria stavolta, è una vera flotta,
Garibaldi per anni comanda una vera flotta, combatte battaglie navali contro gli argentini,
e se uno va oggi a Montevideo, capitale dell'Uruguay, al porto ci trova la statua di Garibaldi,
comandante della Marina Nazionale dal 1842 al 48.
E quindi combatte, e combatte in queste guerre sudamericane che sono guerre durissime.
Questo va sottolineato, non sono certo guerre da gentiluomini, sono guerre dove molti massacrano
i prigionieri, sgozzano i prigionieri senza farsi problemi, dove si saccheggia, si distrugge.
Garibaldi ha un ruolo particolare, comanda delle navi da guerra e fa il corsaro.
Il corsaro, come sapete, che è una cosa diversissima dal pirata, è quel comandante di una nave,
di un governo regolare che ha l'autorizzazione del suo governo di fare la guerra alle navi
delle potenze nemiche, e quindi intercettando in mare anche le navi mercantili delle potenze
nemiche, impadronendosi del loro carico.
Questa guerra durissima Garibaldi la fa senza esclusione di colpi, combatte molti combattimenti,
ha delle vittorie, ha delle sconfitte, vede ammazzati i suoi amici intorno a sé, viene ferito,
fa quello che fanno tutti i comandanti in guerra, requisisce bestiame, requisisce le
derrate per nutrire i suoi uomini, sequestra appunto navi mercantili con i loro carichi,
in un contesto che è quello della però legalità internazionale delle guerre, e regolarmente,
sia alla fine della guerra di indipendenza del Rio Grande, sia alla fine della guerra di
indipendenza dell'Uruguay, si ritrova disoccupato e senza un soldo, perché non ha preso un soldo
da nessuna parte, e ricomincia tranquillamente a fare il mercante di pastasciutta o il marinaio,
il capitano di lungo corso. Su Garibaldi in Sud America vorrei ancora citare un paio di
testimonianze contemporanee che vengono dai suoi avversari. La guerra dell'Uruguay contro
l'Argentina a un certo punto si risolve anche perché l'Inghilterra si è stufata, e l'Inghilterra
a quell'epoca, lo abbiamo già capito, nel mondo più o meno fa quello che vuole. Gli inglesi
sono convinti che questa guerra per l'indipendenza dell'Uruguay è una farsa, che in realtà è
tutta una storia di politicanti locali, di mafie locali, che non c'è nessunissimo idealismo
da nessuna parte, e quindi a un certo punto mandano un loro inviato, Lord Hoden, con l'incarico
di imporre la pace. E Lord Hoden arriva, impone la pace, poi torna a Londra. Fa una relazione
a Londra assolutamente ostile agli uruguayani, dove dice sì, sì, sì, questi parlano tanto
di libertà, di indipendenza, ma in realtà appunto sono tutte mafie locali, e poi dice
Lord Hoden in Parlamento a Londra. Sono contento però di aver incontrato un uomo che era l'unico
che meritava stima. Il solo e l'unico disinteressato tra gente che perseguiva soltanto il suo interesse
personale. Una persona di grande coraggio e di grande talento militare, che ha assolutamente
diritto alla nostra simpatia. Così Lord Hoden nel Parlamento inglese di un Garibaldi che appunto
serviva il governo uruguayano, a cui gli inglesi erano assolutamente ostili. Citerei ancora una
corrispondenza fra il dittatore dell'Argentina, Rosas, e uno dei suoi luogotenenti, Oribe.
L'Argentina è il paese contro cui Garibaldi ha combattuto per anni, e infatti, piccola
parentesi, l'Argentina è forse l'unico paese sudamericano in cui oggi Garibaldi non è
popolarissimo. È popolare per forza, perché l'Argentina è per metà popolata da italiani,
e tuttavia c'è pur sempre il ricordo che nelle grandi guerre ottocentesche Garibaldi stava
dall'altra parte. A un certo punto il dittatore argentino offre 30.000 dollari a Garibaldi
perché diserti e passi dall'altra parte, e manda un suo inviato con questo incarico di
fare la proposta a Garibaldi. E gli dice, gli scrive, devi cercare di accaparrarti il
gringo Garibaldi, che è l'ispiratore dei selvaggi assediati in Montevideo, selvaggi uno degli epiteti
con cui reciprocamente ci si gratificava durante queste guerre sudamericane. Senza badare a spese,
devi dargli tutto il denaro che chiede, dato che i selvaggi non gliene hanno dato affatto,
nemmeno per le candele. In altre parole, Garibaldi è senza un soldo, perciò compriamolo.
L'inviato del dittatore argentino Rosas risponde, ho usato tutti i mezzi possibili, ma non è possibile
comprarlo. È un selvaggio dalla testa dura. E dunque, immaginiamo di voler fare una cosa che
gli storici non dovrebbero fare, ma che invece il pubblico fa volentieri, proviamo a giudicare,
proviamo a giudicare quest'uomo. E proviamo però a giudicarlo, cosa che è anche legittima
naturalmente, stando però all'interno della realtà storica, non inventandoci le cose. Se
noi volessimo fare un ritratto poco simpatico di Garibaldi, nelle fonti, anche le fonti relative
al suo periodo sudamericano, non troviamo assolutamente niente di quelle accuse che invece oggi si rincorrono
su certi siti internet, appunto, di essere stato un pirata, aver rubato, essersi arricchito,
non c'è assolutamente niente del genere. Se volessimo fare un ritratto, come dire, negativo
di Garibaldi, potremmo certamente dire che era uno che si arruolava facilmente per una
causa senza magari rifletterci tanto su. Potremmo certamente dire, come hanno detto in tanti già
al suo tempo, che era un ingenuo, appunto, un idealista, uno che il mondo non lo capiva
mica tanto, che viveva in un suo mondo di sogno. Questo potremmo anche dirlo. Un impolitico,
uno che di politica effettivamente è la politica vera, politicata, dell'intrigo, non ha mai
capito niente. Un esaltato e dunque anche pericoloso, come molti lo ritenevano pericoloso,
non perché fosse un bandito, ma perché era uno che non si sapeva mai cosa faceva.
Questo noi probabilmente potremmo dirlo. Se però poi andiamo a vedere quali erano le
opinioni politiche di Garibaldi, quali erano cioè le cause per cui lui si è esposto, per
cui ha parlato, che cos'era che propugnava, quando lo intervistavano quali erano i suoi ideali,
di cosa veniva fuori dai suoi discorsi. E qui adesso vi faccio un elenco delle posizioni
politiche che Garibaldi ha preso nel corso della sua vita. Che fosse repubblicano va da
sene, per fine inutile dirlo, anche se ci torneremo su. Garibaldi era per l'abolizione
della pena di morte. Era per l'imposta progressiva sul reddito, cosa che a noi oggi può sembrare
ovvia. Ma badate bene che l'imposta progressiva sul reddito, cioè il fatto che chi guadagna
di più paga anche in percentuale di più, allora non esisteva da nessuna parte. E lo
stesso Cavour, che pure era un uomo che ha governato con le tasse, l'imposta progressiva
sul reddito non l'ha mai voluta, dicendo che era l'anticamera del comunismo. Dunque non
era una posizione ovvia sostenerla, Garibaldi la sosteneva. Va da sé che era per l'istruzione
obbligatoria, gratuita e laica. Era per l'allargamento del suffragio fino ad arrivare al suffragio
universale, in un mondo in cui i parlamenti erano eletti soltanto dalla parte più agiata
della popolazione. Era per l'abolizione dei titoli nobiliari, e va bene. Quando si trattava
di operai di proletariato e di rivoluzione, Garibaldi ha sempre preso una posizione chiarissima.
Quest'uomo, che la regina Vittoria chiamava un rivoluzionario, ha dichiarato che la rivoluzione
è, cito, un cataclisma sociale che nessun di noi vorrebbe testimoniare. È proprio per
questo che Marx ce l'ha con lui, naturalmente. Dopodiché lui si identifica, sia ben chiaro,
con il proletariato. Lui si considera un proletario e quando va in Inghilterra e lo invitano ai banchetti
dei sindacalisti e degli operai, lui fa dei discorsi in cui dice di essere ben lieto di
essere stato accolto dal proletariato, la classe a cui ho l'onore di appartenere. Ma il proletariato
va sostenuto, favorendo i sindacati, favorendo le società di mutua assistenza, con il lavoro
per tutti e non le elemosine o i sussidi. Ancora, in questo elenco delle posizioni politiche
di Garibaldi, che tutto sommato, per essere di un uomo che era giudicato ingenuo, ignorante,
impolitico, che non capiva niente, non sono poi così, invece, così scadenti. Garibaldi
è un nazionalista, naturalmente, nel senso che è un patriota. Finora abbiamo presentato
il Garibaldi cosmopolita, che mette la sua sciabola al servizio dei governi rivoluzionari
in tutto il Sud America, ma poi, nella seconda parte della sua vita, sarà soprattutto un
patriota italiano. Ma Garibaldi ha ben chiaro, e lo dice sempre, che lui è pronto a combattere
e a farsi ammazzare per l'Italia, finché si tratta di guerre di liberazione. Dichiara
anche che se mai l'Italia dovesse opprimere altre nazioni, lui combatterebbe contro l'Italia.
La sua è l'epoca in cui comincia il colonialismo, anche per l'Italia. Garibaldi è ostile al
colonialismo. È a favore di una lega delle nazioni e dell'arbitrato internazionale per
risolvere le controversie fra i popoli. Può sembrare buffo per un uomo che ha servito
in sei eserciti diversi, e che per gran parte della sua vita è stato conosciuto semplicemente
come il generale Garibaldi, ma Garibaldi ha, fra i suoi temi preferiti, la lotta al militarismo.
Secondo lui non ci dovrebbero essere eserciti professionali, ma gli stati dovrebbero avere
soltanto milizie di liberi cittadini. Quando è in Parlamento è per i tagli al bilancio
militare, e in vecchiaia prende posizioni addirittura pacifiste.
Ancora un esempio, non sto facendo della geografia, e sia chiaro. Garibaldi un sacco di gente al
suo tempo l'ha considerato un ingenuo e uno stupido anche, può anche darsi. Io sto dicendo
delle cose che risultano dai fatti. Quando scoppia la guerra civile americana, voi sapete
che la guerra civile americana ha, alla sua base, da un lato ragioni economiche e dall'altro
ragioni ideali. Lo scontro fra il Nord e il Sud è lo scontro fra due parti degli Stati
Uniti che hanno interessi molto diversi. E al tempo stesso è anche una guerra che nel
Nord i nemici della schiavitù sperano potrà portare ad abolire la schiavitù. Scusate se
mi fermo su questo, ma è importante per capire la posizione di Garibaldi. Questa faccenda
della schiavitù all'inizio non è affatto dichiarata come la vera ragione della guerra
civile americana. Perché gli abolizionisti non sono così popolari neanche al Nord. E
in realtà il presidente Lincoln interessa salvaguardare l'Unione e, semmai, la prevalenza
del Nord sul Sud, ma soprattutto salvaguardare l'Unione. E nei primi anni di guerra la schiavitù
non è assolutamente parte del suo programma. Ora Lincoln, appena scoppiata la guerra, manda
chiamare Garibaldi offrendogli un comando nell'esercito degli Stati Uniti del Nord. E
Garibaldi dimostra anche in questo caso, inaspettatamente, una straordinaria chiarezza di idee. E cioè dice
ma questa guerra è per l'abolizione della schiavitù. Se è così, vengo subito. E l'inviato americano
gli dice sì, sì, sì, certo, certo, è chiaro, è per l'abolizione della schiavitù. E Garibaldi
dice allora il presidente ha fatto un proclama dove abolisce la schiavitù. E l'inviato americano
dice ma veramente no, è prova a spiegargli che ci sono molte ragioni politiche per cui
sì, poi in realtà Lincoln aveva abolito la schiavitù a un certo punto negli Stati
ribelli, mantenendola in vigore negli Stati invece del Nord. Garibaldi dice molto chiaramente
quando abolisce la schiavitù io sono pronto, vengo. Finché non lo fa non mi risulta che
questa sia una guerra per la libertà, quindi non vengo. Questa stessa, come dire, chiarezza
di visione, almeno quando si tratta dei grandi principi, Garibaldi la dimostra durante i momenti
cruciali del Risorgimento. Ci avviciniamo insomma alle vicende fondamentali che ci interessano
di più. Garibaldi, repubblicano e repubblicano convinto, fa la sua scelta molto presto, già
dal 48. Già dal 48 Garibaldi decide che l'unità, non l'unità d'Italia, ma la libertà d'Italia
che innanzitutto vuol dire cacciare gli austriaci e poi vuol dire cacciare i governi impopolari
e corrotti del Papa, dei Borboni e così via. Bene, Garibaldi decide che questa unità si può
fare soltanto con l'esercito piemontese, si può fare soltanto con i Savoia e dichiara
ufficialmente e poi continua sempre a dichiarare che lui, repubblicano, è pronto a mettersi
al servizio del re e a servirlo lealmente, perché quello è l'unico modo di fare la libertà
d'Italia. Io fui repubblicano, ma quando seppi che Carlo Alberto si era fatto campione
d'Italia, io ho giurato dubidirlo e seguitare fedelmente la sua bandiera. Carlo Alberto sia
dunque il nostro capo, il nostro simbolo. E poi ancora più tardi, dopo la grande delusione
di Carlo Alberto, nel 59, quando sta per scoppiare la seconda guerra di indipendenza e chi di
voi c'era ieri si ricorda che il re Vittorio Emanuele II è felicissimo perché finalmente
è nel suo elemento, potrà comandare l'esercito in guerra e però ci sono dei dubbi nel governo,
Cavour non è tanto contento perché è convinto che il re sia un incapace, un incompetente
e che quindi sarebbe meglio se non lo comandasse lui l'esercito. Ebbene Garibaldi prende posizione.
Credo necessario che il re sia alla testa dell'esercito e lasciar dire quei che lo trattano
di incapacità. Ciò farà tacere le gelosie e le ciarle che disgraziatamente fanno uno degli
attributi di noi italiani. E dunque il re al potere e, mi scuserete, ne cito ancora una
perché è importante vedere lungo tutta la vita di Garibaldi questa estrema coerenza
nel decidere che sono inutili le polemiche, sono inutili le discussioni, è evidente nei
fatti che senza la monarchia sabauda l'Italia non si fa e quindi, appunto, è inutile discutere.
E' così. La provvidenza fece dono all'Italia, è sempre Garibaldi che parla dopo la fine
dell'impresa dei mille, nel momento in cui ha consegnato il mezzogiorno a Vittorio,
l'incontro di Teano. La provvidenza fece dono all'Italia di Vittorio Emanuele. Ogni italiano
deve rannodarsi a lui, serrarsi intorno a lui. Accanto al regalantuomo ogni gara deve
sparire, ogni rancore dissiparsi. E dunque Garibaldi è estremamente coerente sempre
nel lasciare in secondo piano i suoi valori, i suoi principi repubblicani e nel prendere
atto che, data la situazione, non si può che avere il re alla guida del movimento nazionale.
Come l'hanno trattato, invece, i Savoia? Perché questa è l'altra faccia del discorso.
Se andiamo a vedere il modo in cui il governo dei Savoia ha trattato Garibaldi, ecco, viene
fuori un quadro molto meno edificante. Già a cominciare da quando il povero Garibaldi
se ne stava abbastanza tranquillo in Sud America a commerciare in spaghetti e commerciava in spaghetti
su alcune barche che lui aveva battezzato Mazzini, Giovane Italia e Giovane Europa. Era un fuggiasco
condannato a morte. L'ambasciatore Sabaudo a Rio de Janeiro, quando scopre che il mazziniano
Garibaldi, fuggito in Brasile, va in giro a commerciare con queste barche a cui ha dato questi
nomi scandalosi e sovversivi, l'ambasciatore Sabaudo a Rio de Janeiro, il conte Borgo Franco,
scrive al ministro degli esteri a Torino. Se mai queste barche di Garibaldi facessero
l'imprudenza di prendere il largo anziché costeggiare sempre e uscissero in acqua internazionali...
Ah, notate, l'altro scandalo è che sull'Amazzini e sulla Giovane Italia Garibaldi inalbera il
tricolore, che è la bandiera che non è di nessuno stato in quel momento e che è quindi
scandalosa e sovversiva. Il conte Borgo Franco, ambasciatore del Regno di Sardegna, dice
se mai prendessero il largo, profitterei della buona disposizione di due capitani della nostra
marina mercantile, discretamente armati, che si sono offerti di seguirle e di finirle. È una
piccola libertà che ci si può prendere in America. Ecco, questo è, come dire, l'atteggiamento
iniziale del governo Sabaudo nei confronti del Garibaldi pericoloso mazziniano esule. Ma nel
48 il governo Sabaudo diventa improvvisamente liberale e Garibaldi accorre a offrire la sua
sciabola. Nel 49 Garibaldi è sempre fra i piedi e la regina Maria Adelaide nel 49 scrive
a suo marito Vittorio Emanuele. Ha sentito dire che si parla di prendere Garibaldi. Si
prendere Garibaldi. Ma angelo mio, che razza di gente! Lo prendono però perché fa sempre
comodo, ma sempre con l'idea che lo si usa finché fa comodo, però lo si manovra, tanto
è un ingenuo e comunque, se poi dovesse andare a finire male, pazienza. Adesso noi parleremo
del momento cruciale, ovviamente, del 60, dell'impresa dei mille. Cominciamo con questo.
Nel 60, quando Garibaldi sbarca a Marsala e a Torino arriva la notizia che Garibaldi
dopo tutto è sbarcato, e non si sapeva se ce la faceva, perché poteva anche darsi che
le navi napoletane lo fermassero. Quando arriva la notizia che Garibaldi dopo tutto è sbarcato,
il re Vittorio, parlando con l'ambasciatore francese, gli dice, eh Dio mio, sarebbe stata
certo una grande disgrazia se gli incrociatori borbonici avessero catturato e impiccato il
mio povero Garibaldi. Ma una sorte così triste sarebbe proprio andato a cercarsela da sé. Le
cose si sarebbero molto semplificate a quel modo. Che bel monumento gli avremmo fatto!
Dopodiché la curiosità che viene a chiunque entri un po' nei segreti di quei mesi e vada
a vedere le carte, come ho cercato di fare io per preparare questo incontro, ovviamente
è di capire quella cosa che nei libri di scuola non ci dicono mai tanto chiaramente,
e cioè, ma Cavour, il governo, erano d'accordo con l'impresa dei mille? Non erano d'accordo?
Li hanno finanziati loro? Li hanno manovrati? Ecco, se uno va a vedere da vicino,
le carte di quei giorni convulsi, perché sono momenti in cui le cose si fanno da un
giorno all'altro, ebbene, si scoprono delle cose che sorprendono chi è abituato a pensare
che i grandi politici facciano la storia con grande preveggenza, manovrando, organizzando
prima. In realtà non è così. In realtà quello che si vede molto chiaramente dalle carte
è che, in sostanza, nell'enorme sconvolgimento di un'Italia che è appena uscita dalla seconda
guerra di indipendenza, sta nascendo il regno, si stanno facendo le annissioni dei principati
di parte dello Stato Pontificio, tutta l'Italia è in subbuglio, anche in Sicilia c'è un'insurrezione
antiborbonica, e a un certo punto si viene a sapere che a Genova si stanno radunando
dei volontari per andare in Sicilia. Ah, e chi li comanda? Garibaldi. E nella corrispondenza
di Cavour si vede Cavour che si consulta con i ministri, con gli amici, con il re, e dicono
che facciamo? Ci sono i volontari che stanno andando e si sa benissimo, tutti sanno che
vogliono andare a invadere il regno di Napoli, a sbarcare in Sicilia, stanno comprando fucili,
gli impediamo di farlo, li arrestiamo tutti? Non si può. Come può un governo che ha preso
la bandiera dell'Italia libera fare una cosa del genere? Il governo cadrebbe subito.
E allora stiamo a vedere, perché magari potrebbe anche venirne fuori qualcosa di buono, non
è detto naturalmente, stiamo un po' a vedere cosa succede. Questo io adesso ho dimenticato
di riportare il libro dove c'erano le citazioni precise dalle lettere di Cavour, ma la sostanza
è molto chiaramente questa. Lui parte, stiamo a vedere, far la figura di arrestarlo noi non
la possiamo fare, perché politicamente è una vergogna, è un suicidio politico, quindi
lasciamolo partire. Non vogliamo neanche far la figura però di averlo lasciato partire.
Diamo ordine alla Marina di arrestarlo, ma l'ordine lo mandiamo quando è già partito.
E diamo ordine all'ammiraglio di fermarli se per caso arrivano in un porto del regno, ma
invece fuori dalle acque territoriali no, non bisogna. Poi sbarcano. Garibaldi, che è
tranquillo, convinto che il re e il governo sono con lui, anche se sotto banco. Garibaldi
sbarca a Marsala, questa è una cosa poco nota, non in camicia rossa, ma indivisa da
generale piemontese, perché lui è ancora generale dell'esercito piemontese dall'anno
prima, dal 59, quando ha combattuto nella guerra d'indipendenza. Garibaldi sbarca indivisa
da generale piemontese e a Torino il governo, come viene fuori dalle lettere di Cavour, dice
beh è sbarcato, stiamo a vedere. Se lo prendono e lo impiccano, pazienza. Invece tutto sommato
arrivano altre notizie, la Sicilia sta insorgendo e allora a quel punto gli lasciano arrivare
altri volontari, Garibaldi è arrivato con mille uomini, ma rapidamente sbarcano altri contingenti,
alla fine a 20.000 volontari Garibaldi, più quelli reclutati in Sicilia. Garibaldi conquista
la Sicilia. A questo punto si pone il grande problema e a Torino discutono, che si fa? Garibaldi
ha già fatto sapere che lui adesso attraversa lo stretto e va a prendere Napoli, glielo lasciamo
fare, lo fermiamo all'ultimo momento, gli consigliamo di fermarsi, perché dopo tutto
a questo punto la Sicilia ci sarebbe già. Vediamo cosa succede, non facciamo la figura
di aver distrutto una dinastia così. Il re Vittorio, e questo è veramente un esempio
magnifico del modo in cui faceva politica il re Vittorio, manda a Garibaldi, la situazione
è chiara, vero? Garibaldi ha preso la Sicilia e a Messina si prepara a traversare. Il re Vittorio
gli manda una lettera ufficiale, che probabilmente gli è stata dettata da Cavour, in cui gli consiglia
di rinunciare a passare sul continente. Dice accontentiamoci della Sicilia, cessiamo la
guerra fra italiani e italiani. Poi l'ufficiale che porta a Garibaldi questa lettera ufficiale
del re, gli porta fuori, tira fuori dalla borsa un'altra lettera privata del re. Lettera
privata in cui il re gli dice, caro Garibaldi, io le ho scritto quello che le ho scritto, ma
lei senta bene, lei mi risponda che è pieno di devozione e di reverenza per il re, che
vorrebbe poter seguire i suoi consigli, ma che i suoi doveri verso l'Italia non glielo
permettono. Dopodiché Garibaldi, con questa lettera in saccoccia, attraversa lo stretto
e comincia la sua marcia trionfale verso Napoli. Molto rapidamente vorrei ricordare, perché
fa parte del contesto, l'immenso entusiasmo internazionale che accompagna l'avanzata di
Garibaldi verso Napoli. In tutta Europa, oltre che in America, c'è un'attenzione spasmodica
dei mass media per quello che succede e c'è un'enorme partecipazione. Arrivano a tutte
le parti volontari o gente che vorrebbe offrirsi volontaria. Ci sono ufficiali francesi, ufficiali
americani, ufficiali dell'esercito inglese in India, perfino ufficiali turchi che scrivono
a Garibaldi dicendo «Se mi vuoi, sono pronto». Gli operai dell'arsenale di Glasgow e gli
scaricatori del porto di Liverpool lavorano gratis il sabato pomeriggio per preparare e
spedire casse di munizioni e casse di medicinali destinate all'esercito di Garibaldi. Un parroco
inglese manda un inno che ha composto lui per chiedere a Dio di proteggere Garibaldi.
Perfino in Russia, alla corte degli zar che ufficialmente sono alleati dei Borboni e che
sono un'altra monarchia reazionaria, legittimista, dove quindi la simpatia per Garibaldi dovrebbe
essere l'ultima cosa, ebbene gli ambasciatori constatano che alla corte di Russia praticamente
tutti sono entusiasti di Garibaldi, fanatici di Garibaldi e ansiosi di vedere come va a finire.
Ma l'anarchico Bakunin, che è in esilio in Siberia, nella città di Irkutsk, ci riferisce
che nella città di Irkutsk, in Siberia, l'intera popolazione aspetta con ansia che
arrivi il giornale per sapere le notizie del progresso di Garibaldi verso Napoli. Garibaldi
come si sa arriva a Napoli molto facilmente, l'esercito borbonico in gran parte si sfalda
e Garibaldi arriva a Napoli in treno. Il sindaco di Napoli è andato incontro già a Salerno
invitandolo a accomodarsi e a entrare a Napoli. Garibaldi entra a Napoli acclamatissimo,
lui forse non ateo perché ha una sua posizione, diciamo così, teista, ma certamente non credente
nel senso convenzionale e ferocemente anticlericale, però ha il buon senso di sapere cosa bisogna
fare. Va immediatamente a trovare San Gennaro e il sangue di San Gennaro si liquefa all'arrivo
di Garibaldi naturalmente. Dopodiché Garibaldi si trova dittatore delle due Sicilie e deve
decidere che cosa fare e a Torino devono decidere che cosa fare in questa situazione pazzesca
che si è creata. Garibaldi per due mesi governa l'ex regno di Napoli con pieni poteri, si dimentica
una cosa sola, non si assegna uno stipendio, non prende un soldo durante quei due mesi in
cui è dittatore del regno di Napoli e deve decidere cosa fare. E qui, per testimonianza
concorda dei contemporanei, viene fuori invece il Garibaldi, come dire, politico non tanto
bravo quando si tratta di amministrare concretamente, perché prende una serie di decisioni anche
contraddittorie. Fa alcune cose che spaventano i conservatori, i liberali, che pure l'hanno
acclamato, per dire crea un sussidio di disoccupazione per i disoccupati. Questa è una cosa che non
piace per niente, è l'anticamera del comunismo tanto per cambiare. Si circonda anche di gente
poco chiara, è ben noto che il ministro degli interni di Francesco II, Don Liborio
Romano, uomo noto per essere ammanicatissimo con la camorra, appena arriva a Garibaldi
gli va incontro, gli offre i suoi servigi e Garibaldi tranquillamente lo prende a suo
servizio. Insomma, la gestione di Garibaldi della dittatura nelle due Sicilie provoca grande
preoccupazione da molte parti, e specialmente a Torino, dove si teme che la situazione precipiti,
perché la paura è sempre che a questo punto l'Italia meridionale diventi un focolaio di
sovversione, di rivoluzione, che arrivino lì i mazziniani, che arrivino lì gli anarchici,
i comunisti, e Garibaldi, gran bravuomo, però non è capace di tenerli a bada, non
capisce niente. Per cui l'umore diventa molto cupo, ed è molto indicativo vedere come in
questo preciso momento, a Torino, nei confronti di Garibaldi, si fanno dei discorsi che poi
negli anni seguenti nessuno storico ufficiale tirerà fuori, naturalmente. Cavour scrive che
Garibaldi si era circondato di mazziniani e di repubblicani della peggior razza, e scrive
Cavour, se Garibaldi persevera per quel cammino funesto in cui si è messo, entro una quindicina
di giorni andremo a ristabilire l'ordine a Napoli, anche a costo di gettare tutti i
Garibaldi a mare. E' un discorso ricorrente questo del buttarli a mare, perché poi qualche
giorno dopo, visto che le cose non migliorano, Vittorio Emanuele decide di entrare nel regno
di Napoli con l'esercito, per prendere in mano la situazione, e Cavour riferisce così
la decisione di mandare l'esercito col re alla testa a entrare nel regno di Napoli.
Vittorio marcerà su Napoli per ridurre alla ragione Garibaldi e per gettare in mare quel
nido di repubblicani rossi e di socialisti demagoghi che si è formato attorno a lui.
Quanto a Vittorio non è da meno, viene sentito parlare di sterminare sino all'ultimo, la canaglia
e canaglia fino alla fine, e così via. Dopodiché, come sapete, non c'è stato nessuno sterminio,
perché Garibaldi, il quale di tutte queste cose non si immaginava neanche lontanamente
e che aveva sempre detto io sono qua a far l'Italia per il re, appena viene a sapere che
il re è entrato con l'esercito del regno di Napoli, gli va incontro tutto festante e
gli regala l'Italia meridionale. Dopodiché lo porta a Napoli e lo presenta ai suoi nuovi
sudditi, i quali applaudono Garibaldi e non applaudono Vittorio, cosa che non rende tanto
contento il re. Dopodiché però, Garibaldi è un ingenuo, sì, ma mica poi tanto, lui finito
tutto questo se ne torna a Caprera a fare il contadino, ma intanto rimane in contatto
con gli amici, segue la politica e il retroscena viene fuori, viene fuori che a Torino, mentre
lui era lì che aveva appena preso Napoli, si parlava di andare a sterminarli tutti e ributtarli
in mare. Garibaldi viene a sapere questo e ci rimane malissimo e a questo punto succede
una scena memorabile, perché Garibaldi nel frattempo è stato eletto in Parlamento, è
stato eletto in parecchie posti, ma lui ha scelto Napoli, tra i molti posti in cui l'avevano
votato, e Garibaldi si presenta in Parlamento, non ci va spesso, non ci va volentieri, ci va
vestito naturalmente col poncio, per cui oggi non lo farebbero entrare naturalmente a Montecitorio
e nemmeno allora voleva intanto farlo entrare, però tenerlo fuori sembrava una cosa, quindi
lo fanno entrare, e Garibaldi, siamo nel 61, nel primo Parlamento dell'Italia Unita, riunito
a Torino, Garibaldi prende la parola, fra grandi aspettative, le tribune piene di Garibaldini,
sostenitori e così via, e Garibaldi comincia il suo discorso dicendo, ho sentito dire che
mentre noi eravamo là, che liberavamo l'Italia meridionale per regalarla al re, qui a Torino
si parlava di mandare le truppe per combattere la rivoluzione, che io Garibaldi avrei personificato,
e poi si rivolge a Cavour e gli dice, lei signor Conte preparava una guerra fratricida, siamo
in Parlamento, un mese e mezzo prima della morte di Cavour, morte improvvisa come sapete,
e che forse, come dire, un pochettino è stata anche facilitata dallo sciocco di questa
giornata memorabile in Parlamento, Garibaldi accusa Cavour in Parlamento di aver voluto
la guerra, preparato la guerra fratricida, Cavour salta su, furibondo, sbatte il pugno
sul banco, grida non è vero, e impone a Garibaldi di ritirare l'accusa, caos, tutti urlano,
tutti gridano, finalmente si fa silenzio, Garibaldi è ancora al podio, aspetta un attimo,
finalmente c'è silenzio, Garibaldi riprende la parola, stavate progettando una guerra
fratricida, a questo punto il Parlamento esplode, si picchiano e così via, e questa
è una delle poche volte che Garibaldi, deputato, è andato in Parlamento.
si fa tardi, chiudiamo, no vi ringrazio, finché non ci caccia non ci buttano a mare, ancora
un pezzettino, no grazie, raccontiamo ancora almeno una vicenda che merita di essere raccontata
perché ci fa capire, come se non lo sapessimo già, che paese è l'Italia. Siamo nel 62,
a Spromonte, cosa vuol dire a Spromonte? Vuol dire che l'Italia è fatta ma manca Roma,
e i patrioti, specialmente quelli più di sinistra, i repubblicani, gli anticlericali,
sono convinti che senza Roma l'Italia non è completa, e sono anche convinti che ci vuole
poco, lo Stato Pontificio è fradicio, crolla, basta rifare come si è fatto con la Sicilia
e con Napoli, mandare dei volontari, e Garibaldi è pronto, raduna dei volontari, va in Sicilia,
ne rapprende altri, si arma, tutto questo sotto lo sguardo un po' esterrefatto delle autorità
militari, delle autorità di polizia che non sanno bene cosa fare, anche perché naturalmente
chi lo sa se il governo non è sotto sotto d'accordo? Magari il governo è d'accordo,
quindi nessuno si prende l'autorità di arrestare Garibaldi, fermarlo e così via. Garibaldi
sbarca in Aspromonte e si prepara a risalire la penisola per andare a prendere Roma con
i suoi volontari. Cavour è morto l'anno prima purtroppo, e quindi il governo forse non ha
più, come dire, le spalle abbastanza larghe, si spaventa. Il re e Ratazzi che governa in
quel momento, per un po' stanno a vedere, è un copione che si ripete, poi si rendono
conto che politicamente non se lo possono permettere. Perché non se lo possono permettere?
Perché Roma è difesa dai francesi, perché l'imperatore Napoleone III che governa la Francia
sostenuto dall'opinione di destra, conservatrice, cattolica, si è fatto protettore del papato,
del regime temporale del papa e la potenza francese non si può certo sfidare. Dopo qualche
sondaggio Vittorio Emanuele e Ratazzi capiscono che la Francia non permetterà all'Italia di
prendere Roma. E allora a questo punto l'unica cosa da fare è fermare Garibaldi.
Mandano a fermare Garibaldi il generale Cialdini, che è uno che l'anno prima, al momento del
famoso intervento di Garibaldi in Parlamento contro Cavour, ha parlato molto violentemente
contro Garibaldi, lo ha anche insultato, gli ha detto che era molto stupito che lui si permettesse
di entrare in Parlamento vestito con un costume così strano, che era poi l'abito con cui aveva
fatto l'Italia unita naturalmente, avevano litigato al punto che Garibaldi aveva sfidato
a duello Cialdini, poi il governo li aveva convinti a rimettersi d'accordo, ma comunque
ecco il governo sceglie proprio Cialdini per andare a fermare Garibaldi. Cialdini affronta
Garibaldi, qui ci sono ovviamente molti rendi caso conti, in parte contrastanti, la versione
più filo Garibaldina dice che Garibaldi è in prima fila, che dice ai suoi non sparate,
non sparate, in realtà molti sparano, c'è una rapida sparatoria, 10 minuti, 12 morti
e 44 feriti in tutto, Cialdini manda un comunicato dove dice che dopo un lungo e disperato combattimento
ha sconfitto i sovversivi, tra i 44 feriti c'è Garibaldi che è stato ferito due volte,
il che vuol dire che avevano ordine di sparare a lui evidentemente, e certo se l'avessero ammazzato
sul momento si sarebbero risparmiati tante grane, invece non muore, lo arrestano, lo spediscono
in fortezza, nel frattempo sul posto Cialdini fa fucilare senza processo parecchi Garibaldini
che erano militari dell'esercito italiano che avevano disertato per unirsi a Garibaldi,
esattamente come tanti avevano fatto due anni prima per unirsi ai mille ed erano stati
poi acclamati e considerati eroi nazionali, stavolta invece quelli che hanno fatto la stessa
cosa vengono fucilati senza processo, molti altri finiscono in galera e sono poi condannati
all'ergastolo, dopo questo scontro di 10 minuti con 12 morti e 44 feriti il governo distribuisce
76 medaglie al valore agli eroici vincitori che hanno sconfitto Garibaldi, dopodiché però
che si fa con Garibaldi? È in prigione, lo processiamo, a questo punto cominciano a tremare
le vene i polsi, provate a immaginare, siamo due anni dopo l'impresa dei mille, processiamo
pubblicamente Garibaldi, ne parlano, ne discutono seriamente, però un tribunale normale no,
a porte aperte no, forse un tribunale militare, ecco si potrebbe un tribunale militare, per
fortuna Garibaldi ha anche degli amici nel mondo politico e questi amici si danno da fare
e salta fuori che mentre Garibaldi radunava i suoi volontari il re gli ha scritto qualche
lettera privata in cui gli diceva bravo Garibaldi continuo noi siamo d'accordo, solita storia
ormai non vi stupite più di niente naturalmente no? Ecco e quindi in questo paese in cui non
bisogna stupirsi di niente fanno balenare al re che se le cose precipitano queste lettere
vengono fuori, a quel punto il governo decide amnistia, colpo di spugna, Garibaldi viene
liberato e non se ne parla più. Garibaldi avrà ancora delle avventure, fa ancora in
tempo a combattere nella terza guerra di indipendenza, quando le cose vanno malissimo, veniamo sbaragliati
come sapete a Custoza, Alissa, Cialdini, l'uomo di Aspromonte è uno dei principali responsabili
della catastrofe di Custoza, Garibaldi ha un comando e tanto già che c'è vince una battaglia,
è l'unico che vince una battaglia in quella guerra disgraziata, a Bezzecca e sta per conquistare
Trento quando lo fermano e lui risponde obbedisco, come tutti sanno, Trento bisognerà
poi aspettare un'altra guerra e 600.000 morti per unificarla all'Italia. Nel 70 c'è l'ultima
straordinaria avventura di Garibaldi, nel 70 c'è la guerra franco-prussiana, la Prussia
e gli altri stati tedeschi dichiarano guerra alla Francia di Napoleone III e la sconfiggono,
Napoleone III cade, la Francia diventa una repubblica. Ho saltato altre cose, ho saltato
Mentana per esempio, ma non posso raccontare tutto. Tenete presente però che Napoleone III è l'uomo
che ha impedito a Garibaldi di conquistare Roma, un avversario, ma quando lui è caduto e la Francia
diventa una repubblica e decide di continuare a combattere la guerra contro la Prussia per difendere
l'indipendenza della Francia contro gli invasori tedeschi, Garibaldi annusa una guerra
per la libertà e decide, lui ormai più che sessantenne, e a quell'epoca si invecchiava
in fretta, lui è artritico, è quasi in sedia a rotelle, decide di andare a combattere per
i francesi. Arriva, quando arriva i francesi sono talmente disperati che lo accettano, gli
danno un comando, Garibaldi combatte l'ultima guerra della sua vita contro i prussiani strapotenti
che stanno stravincendo la guerra contro la Francia, a Garibaldi assegnano la difesa
di Dijone e della Borgogna, se la cava passabilmente, combatte diversi scontri, ne vince qualcuno,
alla fine difende Dijone, impedisce ai prussiani di conquistarla, non riesce più ad andare a
cavallo, lo portano in carrozza, ma comunque se la cava egregiamente, in un piccolo combattimento
per di più i Garibaldini catturano una bandiera prussiana, è l'unica bandiera che i prussiani
hanno perso in tutta la guerra franco-prussiana, dopodiché sull'onda dell'entusiasmo viene
eletto deputato al Parlamento della Repubblica Francese. Quando arriva al Parlamento della
Repubblica Francese è la bagarre, perché in realtà ai francesi, immaginate quanto sono
contenti che è arrivato Garibaldi dall'Italia, è l'unico che non si è fatto sconfiggere, è
l'unico che ha preso la bandiera prussiana. Per di più in questo Parlamento c'è una maggioranza
comunque conservatrice, clericale, che non perdona a Garibaldi le sue posizioni politiche,
quindi succede questa cosa scandalosa che Garibaldi arriva al Parlamento dove è stato
eletto e non vogliono farlo parlare sostenendo che lui non è francese e quindi non è valida
la sua elezione. Il bello è che lui era nato suddito francese, fra l'altro, a Nizza nel
7, ma comunque. Bagarre, alla fine lo fanno parlare, ma c'è una tale opposizione, un tale
scandalo che lui se ne va indignato. Dopodiché Victor Hugo prende la parola e dice al Parlamento
vergognatevi, Garibaldi è l'unico generale francese che non è stato battuto in questa
guerra. Bagarre di nuovo si dimette anche a Victor Hugo, eccetera, eccetera. Garibaldi
se ne torna a Caprera, per questa volta ne ha abbastanza. È vecchio, muore pochi anni
dopo, pochi non pochissimi, c'è ancora qualche annetto se la cava, ma ha una lunga vecchiaia
e io vorrei leggere uno dei tanti commenti sulla morte di Garibaldi. Ovviamente la morte
di Garibaldi è una notizia da prima pagina nei giornali di tutto il mondo, commenti, analisi
di tutti i tipi, in privato tutti quanti parlano di questa cosa. Io vorrei leggere il commento
di una principessa inglese, Vicky, figlia della regina Vittoria, sappiamo già quanto
la regina Vittoria ammasse Garibaldi. Questa è sua figlia, che per di più ha sposato il
principe ereditario di Germania e quindi sarà imperatrice di Germania. Questo quindi è un
commento che viene, come potete immaginare, da parte di qualcuno che non era proprio portato
a avere simpatia per Garibaldi e per tutto quello che rappresentava. Ecco, la principessa
Vittoria, presto imperatrice di Germania, scrive nel suo diario, anzi no, scrive alla
mamma, Vittoria. Così il povero vecchio Garibaldi è morto alla fine. A dispetto di tutte le ridicole
mistificazioni, di tutti gli equivoci cui il suo nome è stato associato, era un eroe e un
patriota e la sua patria gli deve molto. Io non sono mai stata capace di reprimere un certo
grado di ammirazione e di simpatia per lui. Ecco, questo secondo me è proprio il minimo,
ma è un minimo che anche nell'Italia di oggi forse dovremmo sforzarci di conservare. Grazie.